you
hi everyone is cherry Amon leach s and
employing a 15-2 game the black end all
right let's try a Sicilian first time
playing against this opponent yeah and I
guess we're going into a Smith more my
normal reply is to decline it after c3
to push d3 but what's actually except at
this time he'll play with this so I'm up
upon but behind development wise hmm
okay
how to set up exactly I have some I have
an idea in mind one that's related to a
d6 e 5 structure also the move of a 6 is
included in this idea a 6 d6 + e5 know
sometimes this pawn will actually go a
couple squares will move twice before he
gets to e5 that much said does it really
matter move order wise which when I go
forward with I think knight c6 is fine
as a start let's do that this a 6 move
that I'm referring to is aimed at
stopping a night jump into this square
b5 and yeah I'm gonna try and get away
with maybe getting in a 5 and one in one
move don't know if I'll be able to
manage that but that's that's what I'm
gonna aim for so that said I think I
could go with first d6
one idea might be to play Bishop g4 in
with the pawn on e5 have this idea in
mind of playing Knight to d4 I think I
need to be a little bit cautious here
because if I play this right away
Knight to g5 could hurt me so I think
this is one of the reasons why you're
not able to really get this moving in
one shot he kind of has to take a pit
stop on this e six square to blunt this
diagonal so I'm guessing a six here on
on Knight f6 I believe II five hits yeah
I don't want to I don't want to allow
that and so I'm a six first there's
tactics I believe in mind with a Knight
f6 push and then maybe some capture on
if f7 so I think e six here yeah I think
II 6 right here well that's you know
let's do a six this 'if I've move I
believe I can play for winter if the
bishop place to f4 pinpointing d6 I can
then play e5 and it will hit with tempo
let's see I'm wondering about still this
a6 move right now or still a little bit
more development with Bishop e7 I don't
believe that this is a threat just yet I
like Bishop e7 it just so it keeps a
close eye over this Knight g5 idea these
are all pretty standard moves on the
white end they've been here before yeah
so I wonder about a six now a six Knight
f6 rook d1 is hitting soon okay yeah
rook d1 is soon to happen and I'm
wondering about this ensuing move of a
five you know trying to take advantage
of the file on the or the pin on the D
file
hmm a six let's say a six rook a d1 and
then e five hmm that's so sure about
that actually how about let's go with
Knight f6 here if Knight f6 rook d1 then
I could play this move and then I'm
threatening to maybe play Bishop g4 and
Knight here huh
I need downside with this we're gonna
find out so I've talked very early about
flowing a6 but I've yet to do it I don't
think that this is a bother just yet
okay b5 right now mm-hmm
I know I weakened d5 but yeah yeah I
don't want to allow this advance let's
go with e5 Bishop g4 and night here so
this is a real this is certainly a
glaring weakness I have a backward d6
pawn but I do have an extra pawn so
let's see what white does here this is I
guess they're first think these are all
pretty standard deployments on the white
end playing the Smith Mora gambit and
yeah I'm certainly taking this one as a
learning experience as mentioned I
normally decline the gambit and push d3
but figured why not mix it up a little
bit so Bishop g5 this might be one idea
to remove let's say the defender of d5
and then drop him in here or h3 I'm
expecting one of those two moves
I don't think Knight b5 is really a
bother I give them a kick and after a
capture Bishop takes there's not really
a way to take advantage of this pin as
far as I could
you know I'm thinking Bishop g5 or h3h3
maybe I play h6 and not even allow this
idea to remove the knight or I can also
just castle if if I'm prevented from
playing Bishop g4 I guess my bishop is
going to play to e6 doesn't have very
many options you know I mean there's a
an ensuing quite natural move after the
bishop moves of rook c1 for white and
they certainly have a lot of play you
know you got all their pieces active
down upon and but they have really good
pieces and a post here on d5 but I'm
still I was still clinging to that extra
pawn that's that's what I have in my
back pocket it's not a completely
healthy one yeah I mean the extra pawn
that I have is really the deep on and
he's uh you know he's not too pretty to
look at you know he's backward and you
know this d5 square is another another
thing all right
so Bishop e3 was decided on I guess okay
so as mentioned earlier with this Knight
b5 idea I said a6 Knight takes Bishop
takes and there isn't a way for like to
take advantage of the pin now there
would be for like if I castle now night
b5 a6 Knight takes Bishop takes Bishop
c5 is then available so I think I need
to address this and so I think now is
the first moment where I really need to
play a six
a six stops might be five one of the
drawbacks is that it weakens b6 is this
an issue they may be running into a fork
right look I kept pretty wild I still
need to castle still need a few moves
before I have the rooks connected one
more to consider here this bishop move
is blocking the Queen sight of efore
directly so this Knight now has a
certain responsibility I may go ahead
and take on e4 at some point um can I
Castle Knight b5 that really is hitting
isn't it or maybe not hanging on for us
or for a moment here yeah I should
really consider castling still I might
be mistaken because Castle vacates ee8
for my knight to retreat and defend d6
if it's if it's hit a bunch of times
maybe I'm okay with that yeah you know
even if somehow they get the piece back
on d6
I think I might be quite fine with that
because in the end they will have traded
the dark square Bishop which is a the
more valuable of the two bishops and I
could think about Knight our Bishop g4
removing this night and then anchoring a
night on the d4 square I'm gonna go with
Castle here and yeah I think night b5 is
not working out might be five a-six
takes Bishop takes Bishop c5 Knight to
e8 and it's still a question as to
whether or not they do get this back
okay scratch that they're just going
with the natural so my considerations
here candidate moves Bishop g4 and a6
okay hmm
Bishop g4 Amex I would expect h3 do I
really maintain the pin and drop back
that's got to be pretty uncomfortable
Bishop g4 h3 Bishop back g4 bishop here
exerting pressure here maybe I could
even sacrifice on g4 if I don't play
Bishop g4 now maybe h3 and then yeah
this move I don't know if I'm such a fan
of it Bishop takes pawn takes Queen here
stuff let's play active let's throw them
in a pin they should probably put an
immediate question in my bishop and I
don't know if I'm going in the wrong
direction with my bishop like this if it
does get kicked around but I still am up
upon what they really want a week in
their Kings side like this we're gonna
find out I think this is at least a
start give him a kick and you know on
the white end kind of learn a little bit
more about the bishop with h3 it's a
useful move for flight square reason and
you know am I gonna take I'm definitely
not going to take I don't think at least
yeah I'd be considering Bishop h5 and
then at least there's no returning you
know in this direction to remedy any
light squares yeah I don't think the
idea you know if I'm playing on the
white end here I wouldn't be wondering
oh if h3 will the bishop play back here
now because this is this is certainly a
useful move so I'm flying Bishop g4 with
the idea to be a pest and maintain this
pin
I think they may have to they may need
to play G far as otherwise this is a bit
too annoying a pin I don't know
follow up moves for me rook to g8 maybe
then a6 and b5
I guess I'm able to do without this a6
move supposin Knight d5 I think I could
take any form back just three minutes
let's see what our white comes up with
here
so if they've pretty much exhausted all
the natural moves in this myth Morris oh
no this is where they're really I guess
having to think this was their first
think Bishop e3 this other stuff is
pretty standard Knights here rooks on
the C and D files Queen Bishop placement
so let's see how they go forward rook
here and I here into here I don't know
if I'd even have that square available
let's back up and at least they have to
consider a possible pea sacrifice so
maybe they a spent some time wondering
if I will sacrifice in g4 which isn't a
completely out of the you know it's
certainly a possibility you know cuz I'd
be up three pounds and that's an
uncomfortable pin and I can have an idea
of King h8 getting out of this pin and
then followed most of f5 might be
interesting because it's not so easy to
get out it's not so easy to get out that
pin and this hits pretty quick I think
at least g4 Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop takes how do you get out of that
pin like how does the Queen move and
still defend the night she can't I mean
I could see maybe an idea of king G -
but then King h8 and then after a Queen
move this is hitting really fast
that might just go for it
and not really try and calculate it
through to its end and just kind of I
don't know roll the dice a little bit
supposed King three uh three pawns for
the piece and yeah that's pretty much
that's pretty much it hmm this Bishop
better not go anywhere he has a super
important job stopping Knight d4 what
would I do in ninety five yeah I think I
still in taking on e4
so if house white doesn't nothing move I
think this is quite good
where else is he gonna go I'm not sure
where my Queen belongs not sure where my
rook on f8 belongs I think I still want
to keep him here for this piece AK idea
with the eventual f5 evening out in time
how does white move forward not quite
sure this would be kind of a Bishop b3
would be like I'm not quite sure what to
do let's that weak in my position but
yeah just back up a little bit stay on
the diagonal you know this could be a
little bit uncomfortable as soon as my
rook place to c8 there's not direct
pressure on the bishop but that indirect
pressure is then placing a certain
restriction on the Queen this has to
defend the bishop so it's maybe a better
square here I wonder also about a 3 B 4
or a 3 in the bishop going all the way
back to a2 just staying out of the
Knights reach don't know not sure how
many candidate moves there are for light
I don't think there can be too many
there's certainly a lot of pieces here I
mean this rook is opposite my queen my
knight can't go too far he has to watch
over this but hang on he's not really
they're attacking
phone for as long as my bishop is here
sure the Queen get out the pin I think I
will take that night out damage the
kingside structure he's the better of
the two bishops that I have these guys
are on tour watch the dark he'll be
there to watch the light fixed pawns is
Row 2 what I'm looking at here they're
really chewing on this one mm-hmm
I think I've played a a blitz game
before where Bishop g4 was Bishop g5 is
played not in this exact position but
the idea at least is to you know meet a
Knight d4 move with giving up the
exchange I don't know that that can
really be recommended here for white but
uh yeah
okay so a3 let's get another move in
pretty quick maybe try to put some
pressure on my opponent clockwise all
right well they weren't really so
rattled where are they mm-hmm actually
you know I might have a sack on this
square now if I take the knight and
there's uh the queen is a bit overloaded
here is she not Bishop takes Knight and
then Knight takes here is discovered
attack against the bishop huh this might
have been too fast would be a mistake I
still I'm up upon
my nights ready to get kicked hmm let's
see
a six huh I think I should take
advantage of this opportunity to take on
f3 I think they'll have to take with
their Jeep on Bishop takes Knight G
takes I should then look to pounce on
those weaknesses around the king namely
f4 and h4 f4 in particular since it
already has a support point so Bishop
takes pawn takes Knight h5 Knight d5 I
could then think about Bishop g5
welcoming a dark square Bishop exchange
that would be beautiful if that happened
I think if such a case comes about light
would do well to maintain the bishop
here just so that it could always be in
a position to take out a knight for when
it arrives on therefore although there
is a knight here that would be defending
that square let's say Bishop takes pawn
takes Knight here and then b4 maybe I
maybe give the pieces back or some
material back just to get rid of this
super valuable dark square Bishop Bishop
takes pawn takes I think yeah I'll
definitely have something to work with
there would they keep the structure as
is and allow me to snatch another pond
although I mean it's not really winning
upon Bishop takes Knight Queen takes
Knight takes pawn bishop takes f5 the
rook takes pawn takes knight and then I
would actually have a knight move with
the discovery against the Queen
when I go for this let's see how they
recapture you know let's see what they
do I'm still fun I still have a pond
that's what I'm holding on to so let's
see what they do if partakes I think
I'll play Knight h5 really quick I don't
think it's worthwhile to do this stuff I
should look to take advantage of the
weaknesses and the weaknesses are f3 f4
with this one pawn capture it's just
these four squares not just these four
squares but yeah four squares are really
in rough shape because of this one
capture he's here directly defending
these two but he has the potential to
defend these two after the capture for
holes on the White King side yeah so
Queen takes I'm going to take on b4
pretty even on time we'll see where the
mistakes are how we can improve
afterwards with stockfish it's a thinker
damage the King side structure or keep
the King side structure and allow me to
grab another poem all right let's go in
this direction right now got to focus on
these squares don't have to but it's I
think it's what the position calls for
so maybe they get their King to the
h-file Knight d5 Bishop here I could
even once my Bishop has moved from e7 I
could think about challenging the night
with 97 I'd really like to have the dark
square Bishop just vanish and then this
would be just a tremendous square for a
knight also you know what I'm just
seeing ideas of maybe this and on Bishop
takes some in-betweener
okay scratch that okay let's go here
right now yes absolutely and therefore I
could take here you know so I'm thinking
the King goes somewhere King h2 seems
maybe better just defending h3 but then
again maybe this move happens with check
at some stage also Bishop takes and then
Queen h4 but it's a lot of squares h4
and f4
I have in mind maybe now Knight d4 is
even a possibility so the move b5
initially I was thinking 97 but let me
first think forward first Knight deform
this bishops pinned and even let's say
on b5 night here Bishop takes maybe I
just take with the pawn and then focus
on these dark squares should it enter an
opposite color Bishop ending or opposite
color Bishop type position mmm the
material won't be so much a factor and
you know I still have these squares to
work with so this is a nice advantage
these these weaknesses are not going
away on the White King side I don't see
how they're you know I don't see them
going away so Bishop takes Bishop on
takes I think his neces would be
necessary this gives a new square
available for my knight not as uh not as
good as square because I don't have a
pond lending support to g3 but you know
so if I was king h2 or h1 would I play
Knight d4 you could try and put pressure
on my opponent king h2 Knight d4 play it
right away maybe and be okay with maybe
giving up on back maybe Knight d4 Bishop
takes I don't go in for this although I
mean why wouldn't I why not just take
the exchange this has to be good the
Queen being able to come up to one of
these two squares they're under a minute
oh okay so my knight is hit yeah I'm
gonna grab another phone yeah this this
shouldn't be too bad now I mean if we
have a bunch of exchanges I have that I
have the better King take with the pawn
or the bishop probably the fisherman the
knight takes this is granting my knight
a wonderful square in e5 I think this is
now certainly busted for white
let's take here yeah dark squares are
just collapsing rooks hit Queen g5 check
Knight d4
let's recapture
Queen g5 maybe queen g4 is played
although 95 hits with the fork ideas of
f3 can't even get this pawn back right
away hmm
this is uh even if it was uh was I gonna
say even if it was even material this
position this would still be good for
black just due to the minor superior
minor piece is a very strong knight in
coming on e5 certainly my first thought
I have to say for King so maybe I'm not
so welcome to Queen exchanges
this opens the diagonal here Queen b6
hits with Czech Queen g5 95 maybe I
retained the checking moves
I think 95 I think he knows his place
yeah let's do this because then Queen g5
Queen G 2 there's I should mention as
soon as this is played there's a
restriction on the Queen now so Queen g5
Queen G 2 is not available because of
Knight takes f3 I could take the rook on
c1 or deploy my Queen right now and then
follow up with Queen g3 let's see um one
two three four five six seven I'm up two
pawns I just want to be as clean as
possible with this one I just really
want to make it simple I don't see how I
could get a rook into the attack against
the White King
oh you know what I could do now
Queen check first the Queen can't block
Queen g5 first Queen g5 if Queen G - I
think Queen G - would need to be played
I don't want to give this pawn up maybe
Brooke takes rook and then b5 they'd be
crazy to take that pawn they'd certainly
have something in this direction missing
something simpler rep takes no I don't
want to take I don't want to allow the
rook to get activity here and maybe I
just go once one or two steps I'm not
sure hmm huh I'm gonna do this
Queen G - I think when G - might be best
yeah because they're gonna get that b7
pawn Knight takes pawn king F - forcing
a Queen trade I don't want a queen trade
I I do not want a queen trade I'm going
to still look to get this pawn but I
want to keep the Queen's on the board
okay now I'm going to save this pawn
yeah and have this support point in mind
rook to you I'm looking for me here
caveman-style play g6 super super
aggressive aggressive and defensive
so Queen h4 okay they're definitely
crawling up into a ball now in fact I
have this move and that'll be gg yeah
that's gonna do the trick
could take here and then play Knight d3
just a super strong night yeah time up
and now they resigned Wow interesting
game as I mentioned I don't have too
much experience at all those of you that
have been uh following long enough when
I see the Smith Morrigan but it's almost
instinctual that I'll just decline it
with d3 but yeah let's click on in the
analysis board and let's go through it
see where there are some improvements
here so accepted where are there some
shifts okay so let's actually take a
quick peek okay so nothing was really
missed but also notice how it was pretty
even all the way up to move 13 so even
though I'm up upon 4 yeah even though
I'm off a pun it's really not it's not
realized as a pond advantage for the
first 13 rows but I guess nothing was
really missed was uh you know favorable
for black it started to go from that
point on but let's see yeah um during
the game I was pointing out if Knight f6
was played maybe e5 hits it's not quite
there well yeah I mean it's still
calling for a 5 right now but it's
there's this e5 move just to point out a
quick trap if d6 Bishop here Knight f6
now now now e5 is a really strong idea
with the night not on c6 defending the
Queen this e5 move is available because
if pawn takes seeing the evaluation go
bonkers
there's the deflection of the Queen and
she's gone but yeah bit of a different
story of course when the night is on c6
so I played that here on the move for D
6 e 6 Bishop e7 yeah I like this idea of
first playing Bishop e7 prior tonight
here just so that this idea of e5 if it
is played it isn't with the fork you
know if he 5 is ever played now I have
an additional option of playing d5 if I
want to but uh yeah Bishop e7 first
pretty pretty even ish did it like
Bishop Gene Bishop e3 oops
Bishop e3 know it popped up for a moment
h3 now it is going to this Bishop e3
move okay I think it also popped up as a
a3 for a second there the castles c1 h6
huh aged six a six like Bishop there
okay all right yeah let's actually look
a little bit at this because I I was
talking a bit about maybe capturing well
it's not really a big fan of that night
here this was my idea
oh maybe there is this is own okay half
point advantage for white but yeah this
has to be pretty tricky
I was uno it's and this might be one of
those where you have to give it some
time to think huh seeing some shifts
here with the evaluation I had mentioned
maybe King g2 and then moving away with
the Queen but yeah this is hitting away
too fast especially with a knight on d5
not supporting this there's the threat
to take this unprotected pawn but what
if Knight d5 wasn't played let's say we
still have g4 takes takes Bishop takes
King G - hmm this was my idea of this
rook h1 a5 was the idea
oh now that's sneaky bishop there that's
something that I had a complete blind
spot 2+2 4 white that's a very clever
move pawn takes there's Bishop takes
Bishop defending everything and now this
well you could just take here or there's
even something better +7 takes h7 and
then a check and then Ike's oh man let's
just carry this one out for a little bit
oh my god getting blasted man crazy
crazy tactics Wow well that's very young
you know because I could see let me just
flip the board for a moment you know I
could see on the white end how you would
be certainly afraid of this pea
sacrifice you know pulling on the white
end if I'm pulling on the white end I'd
be wandering off g4 are they gonna sack
the night and you know this could easily
be consumed by this pin and this idea of
f5 our King here and then f5 but notice
notice the positives as well the king is
going in the corner if f5 is played g8
is can under control and as we're seeing
there are these uh attacking
possibilities of King G - rook h1 huh
this sack of this sacrificed piece by
the way is uh the key the best defender
for blacks King side so you can also
view it as that yes you're giving up a
peaceful look
is it in relation to the position and
he's the most valuable one might say the
most valuable a defender for the black
side that's interesting it's definitely
interesting let's go back to the black
in here so g4 could have been played
went with this hold on one moment h3 I
backed up still even this is right where
change right around here
rook c8 and then b4 yeah that's the
first issue the better move was g4 this
is the computer line with this Knight
transfer still the computer line that's
I must say a difficult move to play not
very human-like and it actually has the
King going back to g8 what is that about
King h7 and then I'm over to later King
g8 sure every human is gonna do that
okay anyhow the idea of g4 was being
called for instead of b4 and then yeah
this is this is gonna be a problem now
pawn takes
takes and then Knight to h5 if Queen
takes am I correct in that Knight tEEX
takes before ya however look at the
evaluation it does go in for this line
to get the material back and then I was
thinking about Knight d5 yeah ID five uh
her name on it
ooh that's sneaky Knight d5 it could
actually take on d5 if rip takes Queen
if there's takes Queen there's actually
rook takes rook first and after Queen
takes Knight takes Bishop Wow so you'd
have to take here first ah yeah because
if you do this then big trouble for
black chop-chop
there goes your queen that's sneaky so I
guess the line is takes rook Queen takes
rook King takes and then this hmm
interesting
it's a valuation of zero Wow well this
is a super strong Knight
I can't kick him out of there any time
soon hmm
Bishop g5 rook check King here
what an interesting imbalance I actually
like white here and I like white here
with this coordination you know even
taking this pawn there's anything wrong
with that no I mean with this right here
notice the coordination just everything
is strung together Knights defending the
pawn and got this rook is he's the only
undefended piece but there's exactly
what you would want in this type of an
unbalanced position for the white side
which is you know white has the
coordination exactly what you need when
you're playing without your queen
Wow I would have been interesting okay
we didn't have Queen takes bishop on
takes and now this is where it's
starting to be quite significant upon
advantage Bishop g5 and then f4 so this
is plus two this is tough now I was
thinking something like this with
throwing a rook on the G file you know
Knight d4 is in there it's too much the
dark squares d4f for h4 yeah too much to
deal with I guess huh Bishop takes Queen
takes Queen here avoiding the Queen
exchange Wow
yeah it's tough
I guess as what you really needed to see
these ideas of you know a soccer fire
discovered tack against the bishop but
then a sacrifice here and should Knight
d5 be played you have this idea of
sacking the Queen the tough to spot but
an interesting imbalance that would have
been going in this direction how it was
played in the game having a poor King
side structure again this uh these are
weaknesses these are problems that just
won't go away
and yeah I know that nothing was missed
from here really I think I really
expressed everything I wanted to I was
just right around this point I want to
make it as clean as possible very
tempting to play this move okay it isn't
calling for that it does call for Queen
h5 I'm glad I spotted that I had some
concern about this is there a drop there
is some drop to that yeah because what
was it here - three and now it's yeah -
three if I took here - 1.7 king of - and
the biggest thing is that the Queen's
are off oh you know I didn't see this
movie there
didn't see that I can move the night
with check and then save my beep on I
was thinking I had to I don't know go
here and then they grabbed this guy I
mean it's still better for black but mmm
not as and that has easily realized this
advantage not as not so easily turned
into a full point with this this
variation yeah certainly just wanted to
keep the Queen's on the safer King
that's the the main reason I'm I'm using
their king of two and yeah it's just a
big problem now yeah I could have shaken
right here one move sooner what did I do
I played b5 I could have taken here one
move sooner with the knight d3 idea okay
it doesn't go away but yeah I should
have seen that right away
like d3 I defended once and then finally
it hit okay um yeah interesting with the
Smith Mora gambit
are you a fan of this Smith Morgana you
play yourself as mentioned when the
first times I'm really accepting it and
learn some things from this one and
maybe you did as well so as usual feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comments section below to this video and
as usual I hope you got something out of
it that's all for now take care bye
you